in 2016 donald trump thought his run for
president would be useful marketing for
his businesses
but trump may have miscalculated from
the get-go
trump was guaranteed to lose at least
one critical stream of revenue
his earnings from the apprentice the
real estate developer
allegedly made 214 million dollars as a
reality star
from 2004 to 2015. his polarizing
politics drove away
more customers than they attracted in
the early days of the 2016 campaign
trump's product licensing partners
distanced themselves in the wake of
controversial comments about mexican
immigrants
and profits as properties suffered too
at trump national doral
the president's most important golf
property profits dropped from 12.4
million dollars to just 4.3 million
dollars in 2017.
all of this helped drive his fortune
down to an estimated 1 billion
since he took office to 2.5 billion
dollars today
and while a loss on election day would
open him up to more federal scrutiny it
could also present money-making
opportunities
if he were to lose the 2020 election
trump could get back in the television
there have been rumors that the
president's family has considered
creating its own station
where trump could presumably serve as
the star and the management
perhaps some product licensing partners
would be interested in renting his name
once again
and foreign business leaders have
already indicated that they are eager to
strike up new deals
any branding business of course requires
having a name that people
think will bolster sales rather than
damage them but
there is hope that he can turn around
his battered brand just look at what
happened to another former president
george w
bush when bush left office in 2009
his favorability rating was just 34
12 points worse than where trump
currently stands according to gallup
nine years later in 2018 a cnn poll
showed 61 percent of americans had a
favorable opinion of the former
president
now of course his 2016 victory wasn't
all bad
and the 2020 defeat wouldn't be all good
either
trump owned condos have been selling at
a premium in las vegas where the
president is more popular than he is in
his hometown
who knows if that would continue if
trump lost the election
trump would also potentially lose many
of his customers at the dc
hotel such as lobbyists and foreign
officials seeking influence
and trump's businesses face pressure
from looming debts
he has more than one billion dollars in
loans leaning against his portfolio
whether he's in office or not trump's
lenders will expect his businesses to
pay back an estimated 900 million
dollars between
2021 and 2024